♪♪
-[ As Harry Styles ]
Oh, hello.
You caught me in the middle of
telling myself a secret.
-Hi, Harry. I am going to
ask you 73 questions.
Ready to do this?
-Come. Come.
-Do you live alone?
-I do.
-And how has your day been
so far?
-Well, I stepped
in a rain puddle
and accidentally got
a ladybug wet,
cried about it
for hours after, but...
I think I made things right,
because that ladybug
is going on tour with me
as my opening act.
-Last person you texted?
-My Uber driver
from three weeks ago,
just to say hello.
-On a scale of 1 to 10,
how excited are you about life?
-A number that I made up
that's impossible to communicate
vocally, only with a look,
specifically this look.
-Least favorite color?
-Ultramarine blue.
-Favorite color?
-Magenta.
-What's the best gift
you ever received?
-A smile.
And you know who gave it to me?
You.
-Wow. Thank you.
What's your favorite meal?
-A bowl of cream
topped with drizzled
raw honey
straight from the bee colony
I'm friends with,
and a handful of wizzle berries.
-I'm sorry, wizzle berries?
-Yes, from the wizzle berry bush
that grows in an enchanted land
that's only accessible
from the old armoire
I keep in my garden.
-What are you scared of?
-Letting my anxieties tear me
away from the present moment.
Wait, no. Spiders.
-What's your guilty pleasure?
-Chocolate.
-Oh, nice. Simple.
-From the set of the original
"Willy Wonka" film.
-Favorite movie?
-Life, directed by me.
Shot with my eyeballs.
Coming soon to theaters
near...and far.
[ Balloon deflates ]
-Best advice you ever got?
-You can save $2 a month
on Netflix
if you get the non-HD version.
-Where'd you get that guitar?
-Guitar Center.
-Where'd you get that piano?
-And what's in your cup?
-Vodka!
-Really?
-No, it's tea.
-How do you take your tea?
-With vodka!
-Dream collaborator?
-Sorry, mate.
I need to get going.
-But we still have so many
questions left.
-I know, but I forgot
I already made plans
to blow a kiss
to my best friend,
a beluga whale wearing
a bellhop outfit.
Thanks for stopping by.
And remember, treat people
with kindness.
Cheers.
[ Door closes ]
♪ Chocolate kisses ♪
♪♪
♪ Chocolate
kisses ♪
♪ Chocolate kisses ♪
I just made that up.